اعبر عن سعاده برؤيتهم بيننا في هذه
الايام السعيده كما ايضا الدول التركيه
الاصل
اسعدت نبي مشاركه مشاركتها على صعيد
الرؤساء وراس الحكومات
[موسيقى]
لن نخذل جميع من
ساندنا ومن اي داب
وجودنا لولايه جديده في
منصب الرئاسه
مره اخرى اقول بانني اشعر بالفخر بتاييد
قرابه 28 مليون
النسمه من الناخبين
ايضا
بالنسبه الينا جميع المواطنين الاتراك
الذين يبلغ عددهم 85 مليون مهمون بالنسبه
الينا
ونحن
دائما كنا عند المسؤوليه وعند الامانه
التي
اوكلنا اياها ومره اخرى اؤكد على اننا
سنكون عند حسن الظن
كما اكدت في كلمتي في مراسم
القسم
مره اخرى
اواجه جميع
محاولات التي تريد احباط
المسيره وان اواصل في خدمه البلد لاوصله
الى مراتب عليا
كما
اعضاء الحكومه من الوزراء اشكرهم جزيل
الشكر الحكومه السابقه
وايضا في الدوره 28
[موسيقى]
مجلس سيكون هناك
مهام توكلوا على عاتقهم
كنواب ومره اخرى اشكرهم لما قدموه
في مناصبهم في الدوره الماضيه
واشكرهم جزيل الشكر واقول لهم بان التاريخ
ستر اسمائهم
باحرف من ذهب واطلب منها من الله سبحانه
وتعالى
ان يرضى عنهم
نحن الان
سنعلن عن التشكيله الوزاريه
الجديده
جمهور باشكاله رئيس او نائب الرئيس
الجمهوريه السيد جوده الماص
[تصفيق]
وزير العداله
وزير
الاس او وزيره الاسره وسياسات
الاسريه
السيده ماهينورج
[تصفيق]
وزير العمل
وزير العمل والسياسات العامه
[تصفيق]
وزاره البيئه والتغير المناخي السيد محمد
اوزه سيكي
[تصفيق]
وزير الخارجيه السيد هاكم فيضان
وزير الطاقه والموارد الطبيعيه
[تصفيق]
وزير الشباب
عثمان اشكنباك السيد عثمان
[تصفيق]
السيد محمد شمشاك
وزير الداخليه
[تصفيق]
محمد نوري ال سوري
وزير التعليم السيد يوسف
مين اللي وزير الدفاع
سيد يشارك
[تصفيق]
وزير الصحه السيد فخر الدين كوجا
هو وزير الصناعات والتكنولوجيا محمد فاتح
[تصفيق]
وزاره
الزراعه والغابات سيد ابراهيم
ووزاره اوزير التجاره السيد عمر بولاط
[تصفيق]
وزير
المواصلات والبنيه التحتيه عبد القادر
هذه القائمه من الاسماء
تشكل الحكومه الجديده والتشكيله الوزاريه
الجديده اتمنى ان تكون خيرا على شعب تركيا
ونتمنى من الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يوفقنا
اتمنى النجاح لجميع الوزراء واشكركم على
اهتمامكم
واحييكم واقول طب ما اساءكم
[تصفيق]
اذن
هذا ما اعلنه قبل قليل الرئيس التركي من
تشكيله حكوميه جديده
وقد عين بموجبها
جوده نائبا للرئيس
وايضا عين
هاكان في دان وزير للخارجيه
وايضا تعيين محمد شمس وزيرا للخزانه
والماليه وعلي برلي قايا وزيرا للداخليه
والرئيس التركي اذا عين بشار جولر وزيرا
للدفاع هذه اسماء ربما وزارات سياديه بما
في ذلك تعيين نائب الرئيس
جوده الماظه نائبا لرئيس